-This is amazing.
I did not -- and I know you, and
I did not know this about you.
The Congressman Seth Moulton
is coming out next.
-Yes.
-He's the Congressman
in Massachusetts' Sixth
Congressional District,
I believe.
-The Sixth Congressional
District, yes.
-And we were texting because
you said,
"I can't believe he's on."
because your great-grandfather
was the Congressman
in that district.
-Yes, and my great-uncle
after him.
-This is the Bates'.
And these are photos of your --
-That's my great-grandfather,
so my grandmother's --
my nana's dad.
-Uh-huh.
-George Bates.
And that's her brother,
William A.K.A. Bill Bates.
And so they served --
and I'm sorry if I'm going to
get it wrong --
from I think the mid' 40s
until 1967.
-That's crazy.
So, a crazy coincidence.
But then you reached out
to your nana today.
-Oh, yes.
-I'm a big fan of your nana.
Yes, you have
a marblehead connection.
-Yes, your nana and my mother
are from the same town
in Massachusetts.
-Yes, we've been
through this before.
But they were in the same
charity musical review.
-Yes, so there's
a lot of coincidences.
-Yeah.
-But you --
You reached out to your nana
to see if there's anything
you wanted me to address
to the Congressman
when he comes out next.
-Yes, she had a few things.
-Okay, great.
-Let me see.
What did she tell me
to tell you?
"Be careful with
his license plate."
Her dad had a special
license plate that everyone
in the town
of Salem, Massachusetts --
Yes, that one...
-Uh-huh.
-...knew because
he was the Congressman.
And she once went to get pizza
when it was new.
This is a long time ago.
[ Laughter ]
Pizza was new to Boston area,
and you could only get it
at a bar.
So she wanted to try pizza.
So she parked the car --
the Congressman's car
outside of a bar,
and it was a real scandal.
-Oh, wow.
-Yeah, back then that's
what a scandal was.
[ Laughter ]
A young woman wanted pizza.
And she also --
She said, "Well,
I know he just got married.
But Seth doesn't need to
bring that up,
because he knows that."
-Okay.
-So you don't need to tell him
that he's married.
-Okay.
-She said, "He should know that
his district was the first to be
Gary-mandered."
And I said --
Yeah, I know.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
I'm with all of you.
[ Laughter ]
I said, "Gerry --"
"No, Gary-mandered is how
it should be pronounced.
Eldridge Gary was --"
and I'm telling you,
but I'm also just quoting her
the whole time,
so please don't think I'm just
telling you this fact --
"He was the first Governor
of Massachusetts,
and he was Vice President
under James Madison.
And I hear that James Madison's
wife did not like him."
[ Laughter ]
So that's town gossip still.
And someone saw that the
districts had been carved into
a strange way and they said,
"That looks like a salamander."
And someone else said,
"No, it's a Gary-mander."
Because Eldridge Gary
had done it.
-Wow.
-I said, "You know, everyone,
and I mean everyone,
says gerrymander."
She said, "Everyone is wrong."
[ Laughter ]
-Well, once again --
-Once again --
-Your nana --
-Nana a million, you zero.
Yeah.
Nana brings the facts.
-She also then said --
I was talking to her
on the phone today about it, you
know, just getting the details.
She goes, "When are
you rehearsing this?"
I said, "Well, it is 4:00 now.
And I'll be there
in a few hours,
so we're never going
to rehearse this."
She goes, "you just go
on television with this?"
I said, "Yeah, yeah.
You okay with that?"
She goes, "Oh,
I'm fine with it."
[ Laughter ]
And yes,
she was very, very excited.
-Well, I'm very excited
to ask him all about this.
-Now -- Sorry, real quick.
Her brother and father were
Republican Congressmen.
-Yeah.
-This seat has gone back
and forth,
Republican and Democrat.
My grandmother with Republican
family, has grown up Republican.
I'm making far more efforts
to explain it to all of you
than she ever would.
She would go,
"I'm a Republican."
And that would be the end of it.
So, she said,
"I like him so much.
I wish he'd come
over to our side,
and I'm here to welcome him."
[ Laughter ]
But then she said,
"You know, I asked my father
once, 'cause all of the
other Irish Catholics --
the Kennedy's, everyone --
they were all Democrats.
I said,
'Why aren't we Democrats?
They seem to have more fun.'
And he said,
'They do have more fun.
But legislation is not
about having fun.
It's serious business.'"
[ Laughter ]
-Truer words.
-That was the end of the call.
-Yeah.
-Very good.
Thank you so much
for being here.
It's always a pleasure.
-My pleasure.
-Can't wait for your shows.
Can't wait for
the Film Spirit Awards.
John Mulaney.